How do you distinguish between
past, present, and future?
Is there really an order to time?
Does it only move forward?
Does it move in any direction at all?
Stop the clock,
abandoned all assumptions
and try to stay calm.
This mind blowing experiment will only
take a few minutes, whatever that means.
This is what if,
and here's how time could be an illusion.
In 1915 Albert Einstein published
his general theory of relativity,
which changed changes and will
change the way we perceive time.
In this groundbreaking theory,
he proposed that the laws of physics
are the same for all non-accelerated
observers. This basically explains why if
you were to watch a car drive past you,
you would interpret the car's passengers
as moving at the same speed as the car.
Since their speed is relative to your
position as an observer on still ground.
Meanwhile,
inside the car,
the passengers feel like
stationary objects since
their motion matches the car's
motion relative to the outside world,
but while Einstein's theory of relative
motion could be applied to all objects
in the universe, he also realized that
one exception to relativity was light.
Light always moves at a constant speed.
These two principles led Einstein to
conceive of a link between time and space,
also known as spacetime.
And one of its tricky implications is
that the perception of how time passes can
be different between two observers
depending on how much faster one is moving
compared to the other.
So if it's possible for two observers to
have to accurate perspectives of time's
passing, but for those
perspectives to be different,
who's clock is right and who's is wrong?
Oddly enough,
they're both right after all the fact
that different times zones exist are
enough proof that your watch and someone's
watching across the world will read
different times every second of the day.
We're inclined to think of the passing
of time as objective or universal since
humans of all more or less agreed on the
same system to organize our busy lives
and to be on the same page with our
neighbors either next door or a few
countries over.
But while time is a convenient tool
for keeping track of the past, present,
and future, the true nature
of time is trickier to grasp.
Once you realize that the past,
present,
and future could all exist at once.
When you look up at the sky,
you might be able to point out
Proxima Centauri after the sun.
Proxima Centauri is the closest star
to earth and it's only about four light
years away, so the light you see now
is actually four years old in our time.
If Proxima Centauri exploded, we would
know about it until four years later.
That's because the speed of light is
constant no matter where you are in the
universe. Another thing you need
to know is the faster you move,
the slower time does.
This explains how astronaut Scott Kelly
spent a year in space and came back to
earth 13 milliseconds younger than
his twin. Now with these two examples,
let's put an astronaut on a planet
that's four light years away.
That means his present is
unfolding four years ahead of you.
Anything you do now on earth
is already in his past,
put simply the past,
present,
and future all exist at once.
Now before you have an existential crisis,
there's a theory that might make living
in the past, present, and future.
All at once, a little easier. It's
called moving spotlight theory,
and it basically argues that there
is only one absolute present,
which changes moment by moment as
if the spotlight is moving over it.
So with that information,
you can begin to see how the passage
of time might be an illusion.
There's no single objective, past,
objective, present, or objective future.
The illusion of time is crafted by our
memories and our experiences and our
upcoming plans, which helped us organize
our life into a neat sequence of events.
But depending on where you
are or how fast you're moving,
that sequence will be very,
very different.
So whether you're new age or nostalgic,
or if you just prefer the present moment,
don't worry, there's a place for
you somewhere in the universe.
It might take you a hundreds of years to
get there, but if you move fast enough,
you'll get there in no time.